president biden's immigration policies
under fire over this heartbreaking video
it shows smugglers dropping two little
girls ages three
and age five over a border wall the
girls were there alone
and they were abandoned thankfully those
children were picked up by border patrol
senator ted cruz blasting the president
for what happened
uh the numbers are through the roof and
as you mentioned a minute ago it is the
direct result
of decisions joe biden made in his very
first week as president biden and kamala
neither one of them wants
wants responsibility for this they can't
fix it
dana just a very pragmatic question as
we start off
here you know what could harris
who's now in charges or president biden
do they've been adding people to speed
the processing of the cases i think it
was a hundred thousand
arrested deported at the border in
february even more in march
they're adding facilities to house
children safely they're opening talks
with latin countries
to stop the future flow what do the
critics think
that the biden harris administration
should be doing oh i actually that's
like the easiest question i could hit a
home run
with that question juan go and go um
okay what could they do first of all
they could swallow some pride
because what they wanted to do when they
first got here was to overturn anything
that president trump had done
and okay so what could they do the
remaining mexico policy
was a great win not just for president
trump for the american people
paying mexico to take care of people
while they waited to hear their cases in
the united states
that was working number two catch and
release they replaced that
okay well what does that happen you g if
you get to america you'll be
if you're caught we'll release you
number three was no deportations
okay and then you have the department of
homeland security secretary saying
we will not deport any children so all
of those
are pull factors right so you could talk
about the push factors the poverty the
violence
the hurricanes all of those things those
are bad but if at the same time
they're pushing and we are pulling by
saying we're not going to send your
children back everything will be fine
if they swallowed their pride and said
we're going to go back and do these
things
that would certainly help it was the
biden administration who said this week
that
they expect tens of thousands of more
children to come through next september
so what are they going to do just keep
opening new facilities and right now
they're using convention centers across
the country
why are they able to do that because
businesses are close there are no
conventions
but at some point i'm assuming that
people in business are going to want to
get back to doing conventions
and a last point about this video i
don't think it's just heartbreaking it's
absolutely outrageous
i want to know what they're going to do
to tackle the cartels
because those guys those are criminals
and we should be doing something to go
after them like in america
if you were a parent and you and you
gave your child
to a smuggler to drop over the other
side of the border
you would be charged with child
endangerment instead what's happening is
they're so desperate they want to get
their children here i know they want
them to be safe i know that mother has
been anguished
but look at those little girls could
have died and so yeah i think they need
to swallow their pride and do something
well i think that they think they're
doing something in keeping with american
values
uh how are any of those things that i
said not within american values
well i think that we have an asylum law
and that's what i want to ask sean duffy
about because
congressman you know where is where is
congress on this
we don't see congress taking action to
set
new rules in terms of the asylum laws in
the country
rules on dreamers rules you know
dealing with the fact that we've got i
think it's 11 million illegal immigrants
in the country it's like congress
is aol when it comes to immigration
reform
one you're absolutely right i mean and
this is not that complicated if you
actually secure the border
um and then you deal with people on the
inside there should be bipartisan
agreement but it seems like
both sides like this fight and can't get
anything done and it's a problem but
what i wonder is we saw that video how
many other scenarios like that are out
there that we didn't have video for
i mean there's no videos of little girls
getting raped or sold into slavery
the number of kids who catch covid uh
the number of you know kids that died in
the rio grande or in the desert
this is horrific policy from uh from the
biden administration
and all of the death all of the rape all
the slavery
sits at the feet of of harrison biden
because it's their policy as dana
mentioned
that has been the poll to to bring these
kids to our border
and and dana's right go back to sound
policy where
i mean if you want to let people in the
country which i disagree with that
have a have a process in place that can
bring people in
that doesn't get them raped and sold
into sex slavery that just that just
makes sense that's humanitarian
that's what parents would do and dana
mentioned this point you can't you can't
say these are great parents
that are letting their their kids come
on these horrific journey journeys with
these criminals
and say they're doing the right thing
because it is a lifelong
sentence if you've been sexually
assaulted you'll deal with it forever
till the day you die
this is horrible agreed
so katie uh now what you're hearing is
people saying well you know vice
president harris has been there now
for several weeks we don't see any big
changes what's she
doing i'm wondering if because she is
seen as more of a liberal than president
biden
could she be like nixon to china could
she get the left to buy in to some
strong border security policies as part
of an
immigration deal
well so far we don't know what she's
doing because they haven't held a press
conference where we can
listen to her and and so far what we
know about what she thinks of what's
going on is she laughed about it so
that's what we know about what the vice
president is doing
but juan to your question about the
asylum issue with congress the remaining
mexico
policy was an asylum policy it forced
people to wait for their asylum claims
to be processed
in mexico and keep in mind the majority
the vast majority of these quote asylum
claims are actually bogus asylum claims
and the biden administration has enabled
people to use certain terms to
say that they claim asylum and that gets
them into the country but back to the
video
the reason this video is so compelling
is because we hear about smuggling
you hear about these stories but now
we're seeing what the smuggling looks
like and we're seeing the ruthlessness
of the cartels and you can watch that
and unfortunately
those little girls getting dropped over
the fences is probably
the least horrific thing that happened
to them when they were being
being smuggled and the biden
administration is engaging
in human trafficking because they are
enabling this to happen and then they're
taking these kids and delivering them to
unvetted quote sponsors in the united
states and when that happened under
obama we found out a lot of those people
were actually sex offenders
themselves so they are enabling and they
are part of this third leg
of this human trafficking process from
central america
and the way that you stop that is by
reimplementing the remaining mexico
issue and saying
you have to claim asylum if it's a real
asylum claim
in your home country not when you get
into the united states
well lauren's sticking with the wall for
a second it was horrific as everybody
said to see the children treated in that
manner dropped over a wall
but doesn't that indicate that walls
don't work
no the wall is supposed to slow to
spread but
it also is supposed to prevent it's a
wall system
it's not just about it's only democrats
that are concerned about the physical
barrier
but it's the wall implemented with a
policy where the
border agents have the funding to go
there and get the people
once they come across the board but this
is a simple fix
we know government can lock things down
so we need two
weeks to slow the surge it's easy just
get the national guard
have them have actual body forget about
the wall
have actual bodies be at the border if
they're good enough for congress
then they're good enough for our border
put them at the border and stop the
criminal enterprise until
our legislators can come up with
legislation to solve the problem
but this back and forth it looks like
democrats
aren't interested in this even obama
wasn't crazy enough
to just allow open borders i mean they
called him deporting
in chief we'll talk about that later in
the program so
what we've seen now is the democratic
party has gone so far
left that now they don't believe that
the nation has a border so the only way
to implement this
and get something right since you guys
don't like walls
let's have a human wall let's give our
national guards the resources that they
need
so they can stop the criminal enterprise
because this is not just a body's issue
in a humanitarian
crisis there are drugs flooding in
across the border
and now it's become aiding and abetting
okay thanks lawrence up next major